Olá vocês sabiam que uma simples lata ou
vidro de conserva como de Milho ou de
palmito que foram mal armazenadas pode
ser um risco sério à saúde aqui quem
fala é Dr Alan Machado Dutra médico há
mais de 25 anos e vou compartilhar com
vocês três doenças perigosas causadas
por intoxicação alimentar ou seja
alimentos contaminados que já provocaram
alguns surtos no Brasil e no mundo Além
disso eu vou passar algumas dicas
importantes sobre como se proteger
dessas doenças as intoxicações
alimentares são responsáveis por cerca
de
420.000 mortes todos os anos ao redor do
mundo pois é é muito triste as crianças
idosos e pessoas com imunidade
comprometida são Especialmente
vulneráveis às complicações que podem
levar a problemas graves infelizmente
até levar ao óbito recentemente tivemos
o caso de uma jovem brasileira que
contraiu botulismo durante uma estadia
nos Estados Unidos trazendo novamente à
tona a importância da segurança
alimentar esse tipo de problema pode ser
causado pela ingestão de alimentos
contaminados especialmente por bactérias
vírus fungos e parasitas e os principais
agentes causadores os mais comuns são as
bactérias como salmonela chigua esquicha
Coli estafilococos e
colostrum pessoal essas intoxicações
alimentares podem ser muito perigosas
mas eu adianto que na maioria das vezes
um sistema de defesa um sistema imune
forte e uma boa saúde intestinal podem
fazer toda a diferença entre apenas o
malestar de alguns dias e uma situação
que exige hospitalização ou até mesmo
que pode resultar em sequelas e mortes a
industrialização dos alimentos apesar de
permitir técnicas mais aprimoradas de
conservação e Controle de Processo
também facilita a produção em larga
escala assim se um lote está contaminado
pode causar surto de grande abrangência
devido à distribuição dos alimentos a
contaminação pode ocorrer em qualquer
etapa da cadeia alimentar e geralmente é
um sinal de más condições sanitárias
como a manipulação dos produtos uso de
matériaprima
contaminada inclusive água contaminada e
controle inadequado de temperatura Isso
inclui o tempo e a temperatura de coz
ento resfriamento processamento e
armazenamento além da contaminação nas
lojas e Supermercados pessoal então
vamos falar das três doenças
relacionadas vamos começar então com a
salmonela provavelmente a bactéria Gran
negativa mais prevalente e a intoxicação
alimentar mais conhecida e que tem sido
um problema sério em todos os lugares
nos últimos anos as bactérias da espécie
salmonela são excretadas nas fezes de
animais infectados e de pessoas pessas
também o que leva a contaminação
normalmente as pessoas são infectadas ao
consumir ovos frango ou porco que não
foram bem cozidos mas atenção também
pode acontecer ao comer lacine os frutos
do mar ou mesmo legumes e verduras
contaminados os sintomas como diarreia
febre e cólicas abdominais geralmente
aparece de 12 a 72 horas após a infecção
e a maioria das pessoas se recupera
dessa infecção por salmonela dentro de 4
a 7 dias para dar um exemplo mais
próximo de nós no ano passado na Bahia
mais de 400 pessoas passaram mal após
consumirem comida de um restaurante
infelizmente houve um caso trágico de
uma mulher que faleceu depois de ser
internada com sintomas graves de
intoxicação alimentar por salmonela
existem vários outros casos registrados
de surto de salmonela pelo mundo por
exemplo nos Estados Unidos a peanut
Corporation enfrentou um surto de
salmonela em seus produtos de amendoim
como resultado
714 pessoas adoeceram e nove morreram
devido à manteiga ou pasta de amendoim
contaminada em 2022 tivemos um surto de
salmonela relacionada ao consumo do
chocolates da kinderovo aquele mesmo que
as crianças adoram esses chocolates
foram produzidos na na Bélgica e
distribuídos em pelo menos 113 países
incluindo o Brasil embora não tenham
sido relatadas mortes O Surto afetou
várias pessoas Muitas delas crianças a
segunda doença que nós vamos mencionar
aqui é a listeriose que é menos
conhecida e menos comum do que outras
doenças da origem alimentar pessoal
apesar do número de pessoas afetadas
geralmente é Menor Ela É de longe a mais
mortal a listéria monocitosis a bactéria
causadora dessa doença não provocam
sintomas típicos de gastroenterites que
são popularmente conhecid como viroses
como cólicas estomacais diarreia e
náuseas Isso significa que muitas vezes
as pessoas não sabem que estão
infectadas até que a doença se manifeste
de uma forma muito mais grave geralmente
como meningite ou septicemia que é
inflamação exagerada e grave do corpo
quando há uma infecção fora de controle
para os idosos recém-nascidos grávidas
ou pessoas com o sistema imune
comprometido a listeriose pode ser
particularmente fatal geralmente essa
infecção se desenvolve muitos dias após
ingestão de alimentos contaminados e
sintomas são dores de cabeça confusão
mental perda de equilíbrio convulsões
febre fadiga e dores musculares que
podem demorar ainda mais para aparecer o
primeiro surto documentado de listeriose
aconteceu na Alemanha entre 1949 e 1957
esse surto foi particularmente trágico
pois estava associado ao consumo de
leite cru e seus derivados por 100
grávidas resultando em vários abortos e
partos prematuros mas não foi um caso
isolado em 1998 nos Estados Unidos um
surto de listéria causado por consumo de
cachorros quentes contaminados afetou
pelo menos 100 pessoas em 24 estados
resultando em 14 mortes de adultos e
quatro abortos em 2002 a carne fatiada
de peru da pilgrims Pride causou um suto
generalizado de listéria em vários
estados americanos levando a sete mortes
e três abortos mais recentemente em 2011
no Colorado 33 pessoas morreram devido a
melões contaminados em 2018 sorvetes
contaminados levaram grande Recall de
produtos nos Estados Unidos surtos de
listeriose T sido relatados em vários
países incluindo Estados Unidos Canadá e
Brasil a África do Sul por exemplo
enfrentou um dos maiores surtos de
listeriose do mundo entre 2017 e 18 com
registro de 800 casos e pelo menos 80
mortes diferente de outros patógenos
alimentares a listéria pode sobreviver
em uma ampla faixa temperatura de -1 até
45º permitindo que sobreviva e se
reproduza mesmo sobre refrigeração ou
até congelamento ela também tolera uma
ampla faixa de PH Sobrevivendo em
condições relativamente ácidas além de
ser razoavelmente resistente a condições
Salinas podendo crescer em até 14% de
cloreto de sódio isso a torna
excepcionalmente difícil de eliminar e
um constante perigo paraa indústria
alimentar vamos falar então sobre o
botulismo uma doença Rara mas
extremamente grave recentemente uma
jovem brasileira durante o intercâmbio
nos Estados Unidos desenvolveu a doença
e teve sérias complicações e agora
precisa da ajuda de aparelhos para
respirar o botulismo é uma doença grave
causada por uma bactéria a colostrum
botulinum que é um bacilo anaeróbico que
produz esporos resistentes e que ficam
presentes no ambiente no solo na água
não tratada e nas plantas embora seja
raro é possível que o botulismo se
desenvolva até mesmo por meio de
aplicação estética do Botox que é muito
utilizado para tratar rugas isso
acontece porque o Botox é produzido pela
mesma bactéria responsável pela doença o
site norte-americano New York post
informou dias atrás que quatro pessoas
foram parar no hospital por complicações
desencadeadas pela aplicação de toxina
botulínica botox que era falsificada de
acordo com a publicação os sintomas
foram semelhantes à doença do botulismo
mas pessoal a forma mais comum de se
contrair o botulismo é através do
consumo de alimentos contaminados essa
bactéria costuma estar presente em
latados em conserv produtos a vácuo que
estão vencidos ou mal conservados alguns
exemplos são palmito picles milho
salsicha queijos e vegetais o mel também
é um potencial causador de botulismo
especialmente em crianças porque contém
esporos dacos trum botulinum esses
esporos estão no ambiente como no solo e
podem ser coletados pelas abelhas junto
com néctar das flores por isso é
recomendado não oferecer mel para
crianças de até um ano de idade a doença
botulismo pode causar paralisia muscular
que dura semanas o maior perigo está nos
músculos que nos ajudam a respirar e o
botulismo pode ser Fatal se paralisar o
sistema respiratório no entanto se for
Tratado de forma adequada é possível
curar doença sem sequelas Geralmente os
sintomas começam de 18 a 36 horas após
exposição uma curiosidade sobre essa
bactéria é que ela tem a particularidade
de afetar o sistema neurológico portanto
os sintomas podem incluir visão tuva
visão dupla queda da pálpebra tontura
boca seca dificuldade de falar e engolir
dificuldade para urinar e para eliminar
fezes e dificuldade respiratória
dependendo da quantidade ingerida a
toxina botulínica pode paralisar até
mesmo todo o sistema digestório
paralisando os músculos respiratórios
pessoal o maior surto de botulismo dos
últimos 40 anos aconteceu em oh nos
Estados Unidos em 2015 esse surto
resultou em 29 pessoas doentes e uma
morte devido à complicações
respiratórias tudo isso relacionado a
batatas enlatadas que foram usadas para
fazer uma salada num evento de igreja em
2022 Doralice Carneiro de 47 anos
comprou um frasco de molho tipo pesto na
Feira Livre que frequentava no distrito
federal e o molho estava contaminado com
a bactéria Doralice passou por uma série
de procedimentos em um hospital para
sobreviver mas ficou infelizmente
tetraplégica por conta das complicações
do botulismo no ano passado uma pessoa
morreu e oito pessoas foram
hospitalizadas após um surto de
botulismo na França depois que as
pessoas comeram sardim conserva
contaminada com bactérias em um
restaurante bem mas e agora o que
podemos fazer para nos proteger e também
proteger a nossa família dessas
intoxicações alimentares primeiro ponto
Man tenha hábitos saudáveis de vida para
um sistema de defesa imune resiliente e
forte para combater essas ameaças
invisíveis segundo ponto vamos seguir
alguns cuidados importantes por exemplo
as bactérias crescem na faixa de
temperatura entre 5 e 60º conhecida como
a Zona de Perigo de temperatura Isso
significa que devemos manter os
alimentos perecíveis bem frios ou Bem
quentes para evitar intoxicações a a
água também é um fator essencial pois as
bactérias precisam dela para crescer por
isso alimentos secos geralmente não
estragam Outro fator importante é o PH a
medida de acidez ou alcalinidade que
também é crucial para controlar o
crescimento bacteriano condições asas
geralmente interrompem o crescimento das
bactérias mas em PH neutro como é o caso
de muitos alimentos a maioria das
bactérias cresc muito bem bem adicionar
um pouco de vinagre ou limão aos
alimentos antes de guardar na geladeira
é um truque simples e eficaz para manter
as bactérias longe Além disso muitas
ervas especiarias como o áo a mostarda o
alecrim e a canela tem propriedades
antimicrobianas naturais é uma boa
pedida utilizá-las falando
especificamente do Palmito é importante
lembrar que o risco do botulismo não é
exclusivo dele mas sim de todas as
conservas mal Preparadas a má reputação
do Palmito em conserva remonta ao surto
de botulismo que aconteceu na década de
90 em resposta aos inúmeros casos a
Anvisa indicou temporariamente a fervura
do alimento antes do consumo mas essa
recomendação foi revogada em 2008 quando
as normas sanitárias foram consolidadas
na indústria há um temor maior do
Palmito porque por ser um produto mais
caro ele é frequentemente retirado
clandestinamente das matas sem controle
sobre esse processo o que acaba
resultando em mais oportunidades para
contaminação é fundamental sempre
comprar Palmitos e outras conservas de
uma boa procedência vindos indústrias
certificadas a embalagem deve ter
informações de origem registro além de
prazo de validade também é importante
para atenção a cor do líquido da
conserva que deve ir do Branco ao
amarelo claro se apresentar outra cor
diferente Ou se o líquido estiver Turvo
isso pode indicar algum tipo de
contaminação então evite qualquer
produto com embalagens enferrujadas
estufadas ou com água muito turva que
são sinais possíveis de contaminação se
abrir as latas ou vidros e sentir um
cheiro forte ou podre obviamente
descarte não consuma Alé Alé disso é
essencial ler o rótulo para verificar
quanto tempo o produto ainda tem de
validade e quanto tempo pode ser
armazenado aberto na geladeira isso é
muito importante muita gente guarda
conservas por tempo demais na geladeira
Então tem que ficar de olho é bem
importante também ficar atento ou atenta
ao abrir uma lata de alimento como peixe
Milho ou ervilha se ela fizer algum som
como se fosse gás escapando não consuma
você também pode aquecer os alimentos em
conserva a uma temperatura acima de 75º
para garantir a segurança especialmente
se estiver fornecendo para idosos
grávidas ou pessoas debilitadas Outro
ponto importante é manter a cozinha
limpa lavar muito bem os alimentos lavar
os vegetais e as frutas deixando sempre
de molho em vinagre ou bicarbonato Não
esqueça de deixar sua pia ou bancada
utensílios e equipamentos sempre limpos
e desinfetados use água quente e sabão
para lavar tudo após cada uso
especialmente depois de manipular carnes
cruas falando em carnes o manuseio
seguro é importante sempre Lave as mãos
antes e depois de tocar em carne crua
use tábuas de corte de vidro diferentes
para carnes cruas e outros alimentos
como legumes para evitar contaminação
cruzada Além disso cozinhe as carnes até
atingirem a temperatura interna segura
de
75º pessoal ao comer em restaurantes
Observe se o estabelecimento parece
Limpo bem mantido não hesite em impedir
que sua comida seja bem cozida
Especialmente quando se trata de carne
de porco e frutos do mar evite maionese
ou salada que fica muito tempo exposta
no balcão e preste atenção em como os
alimentos são servidos se algo parecer
ou cheirar estranho O melhor é fazer é
sempre evitar
compartilhe os vídeos faç bem a vida de
alguém pode mudar
[Música]
também não esqueça de curtir esse vídeo
compartilhar com seus amigos e
familiares para quem precisa dessa
informação sua participação é muito
importante é essencial para continuarmos
abordando temas tão importantes pra
nossa saúde muito obrigado pela sua
atenção um grande abraço um beijo no seu
coração você é feira